- Speaking of musical talent,
good singers and musicians
always impress me,
all right, but, you know
what also blows me away?
It's the things I can't do.
And we have a talented beatboxer, alright?
It's a skill, it's a
skill that I don't have,
but I can definitely appreciate and I try
and do it when no one's around.
(Laughter)
- (giggles) Or I'm drunk.
And when you're drunk, you
think everything's great.
There's a beatboxer
blowing up on social media
right now.
He's so good, Will Smith has become a fan.
Take a look at the video
that started it all.
(beat boxing)
- I'm Spongebob.
- Hi, Patrick.
(beat boxing)
- Hey, Spongebob. (beatboxing)
- That's crazy, right?
I, okay. Well, that beat
boxer's name is Verbal Ace,
and he's here today.
Ya'll, stand up. (whooping)(clapping)
[Kelly] Ya'll give it up for Verbal Ace.
(clapping)
[Kelly] I need..
- First of all, first of
all, I have a question.
Like, as a vocalist.
Does that hurt?
Verbal Ace - It used to. (laughter)
[Kelly] Oh, you just trained
it, for that. I'm like
all like, breathing in and out. WHOO!
That's gotta be rough on the chords.
- Yeah, that's the first
thing I actually had to learn
how to do is breathe,
beacause I used to just do
it until I'd run out of breath.
Like (beatboxing) ugh.
- My God, even that was cool, and that was
probably so simple for
you, but I'm blown away.
Oh my gosh, okay, so you got
to beatbox with Will Smith.
[Kelly] Like, how did that happen?
[Verbal Ace] Uh, it all
started when I was a kid.
I would try to make sounds,
the same sounds I hear
in video games.
You know, play video
game (beatboxing) boom.
Game over,[Kelly] Oh my gosh.
-And um, put stuff out on
social media, um, I have like
over 250M views throughout
my whole social media. (clapping)
[Kelly] What?
- And this all started with
Will Smith's post, the one
at the airport clip on
his social media, and then
he posted another video the
same day saying he was obsessed.
And um, I actually had the
opportunity to surprise him
on a tv show in London, and um,
I didn't think he was going
to be there, cause it's
Will Smith, come on.
When I finally walked out
onstage, and I beatboxed
he screamed when he saw me.
And um, I had to, I had to
stay, I had to keep preforming
cause it's the first
time I'd met him in person.
So, in my head, I was still
doing the [Kelly] You're freaking out.
- But you know, on camera,
I was like hey what's up.
- You're like, its no big
deal. You're will smith,
it's fine. Its fine.
[Verbal Ace] Yeah, and it all
felt like a dream come true
like, I still couldn't
believe it happened.
[Kelly] That's so amazing, man.
(clapping)
- That's so cool. Well, if
it's good enough for the
Fresh Prince, let's see
what you got. Go ahead.
(beatboxing)
(laughter)
(clapping)
[Kelly] (sings)
(clapping) (laughter)
- I just, I just, Verbal Ace,
I just gave away my secret.
Any time I get lost in a
song, I do the Envogue (sings)
- Like I know I am, but that sounds good.
You're awesome man, you're fantastic.